what is idolatry when I make an image of
anything in heaven on Earth or in the
sea that I take as a God or a goddess
I'm saying this is a god this is a
goddess alongside of or in place of
Yahweh and I'm looking to that one as my
god or goddess that I depend on that's
idolatry this is why when the
Israelites started worship
the idols of the false gods B and
ashir and then they started worshiping
the bronze serpent with the gods and
goddesses making the bronze serpent into
a God that's when the bronze serpent was
destroyed 2 Kings 18 ver1 and4 notice
when the bronze serpent was
destroyed in the third year of hos son
of
Ilah the king of Israel he the son of
ahaz King of Judah became king watch he
was 25 years old when he became king and
he reigned 29
years in Jerusalem his mother's name was
Abby daughter of
Zechariah he did what was right in the
sight of the Lord notice he did what
made God happy in God's sight you can do
things that are right in the sight of
the world and get God angry or you can
do things that are right in God's sight
and have the world hate
you according to everything that David
his father done not watch he removed the
high places now why the high places
because in the high places the isites
would build altars to false gods and
goddesses and build Idols to false gods
and goddesses like B and as or ishar Ash
and worship them notice when the bronze
serpent is destroyed he removed the high
places Watch broke down the sacred
pillars some believe these are phic
symbols representing male and female
organs cut down the ashir that was a
false goddess the wife of e crushed the
bronze serpent that Moses had made now
he destroyed the bronze serpent why for
until those days the children of Israel
had made offerings to it they called it
nushan do you see when the bronze
serpent
became an
idol when it
was
combined with Idols of gods and
goddesses and phallic
symbols that the Israelites started
worshiping as gods and
goddesses alongside of Yahweh then it
became an idol because it was taken as a
Divinity and it had to be destroyed so
idolatry is when you make an image of a
thing that you view as a god or goddess
that you belong to that you answer to
that you look to for salvation and for
your daily needs that's
idolatry idolatry is not having an icon
image of a creature that you know as a
creature that you don't see as a god or
goddess that you don't worship as a god
or goddess that is not
idolatry last time I checked I'm not
aware of any Orthodox or Catholic that
thinks Mary is a goddess
and they worship her as a goddess last
time I
checked I don't recall any Orthodox or
Catholic that thinks the
icon of
Peter is an icon of a God that they
worship as a God and look to as a
God it is no more
idolatrous for you to have an image of
the holy mother that you kiss showing
your love for her as a creature created
by Jesus owned by Jesus then you take a
picture of your dead mother and kiss it
it is no more
idolatrous to kiss an icon of John the
Baptist
or of ignacius or polycarp whoever
Paul because you acknowledge them as
creatures created by God filled with the
spirit used mightily by God whom God
exalted because they love Jesus so much
then having a picture of your daughter
or your son or your brother or your
father and kissing that picture because
of how near and dear they are to your
heart and let me show you the hypocrisy
of
Protestants do you
have children that you allow to watch
cartoons of IAL stories if you're a
Protestant do you have children that you
allow to watch cartoons of biblical
figures whether they Jesus or
Abraham have you watched and do you
watch movies played by actors depicting
Jesus Mary the apostles Moses and
Abraham yes or no now I'm going to turn
your ARG against
you number one why are you watching and
why are your kids watching or why are
your kids
reading children Bibles with images
drawings of Jesus Mary the prophets when
we don't know what they look like that's
your argument isn't it well we don't
know what they look
like well you don't know what they look
like so then how dare you let them watch
cartoons you don't know what Jesus looks
like you don't knowy looks like how dare
you watch movies where actors depict
Jesus or Mary or Peter or Moses you
don't know what they look like see
you're being inconsistent that was my
point you don't see your hypocrisy and
your inconsistency you don't know you
don't need to know what they look like
as long as you know that this image
represents Jesus in other words oh that
cartoon that's supposed to be Jesus as
long as the image in folks in your heart
and mind
Jesus the Lord will not condemn you so
it's okay for you to have them depict
the story using images when you don't
know who Jesus is but it's not okay for
a preliterate society many people are
uneducated iller it could not read or
write have no
televisions no televisions no Netflix
but it's not okay for them to have icons
and statues as visual
reminders of the host of Heaven and the
godhead that's not okay you see your
inconsistency your dishonesty your
deception do you know what Jesus is
called in Colossians
1:15 yeah especially those of you in
Christmas how many of you have an
image of the nativity
scene at your church in your church on
your lawn or in your home and an image
of the nativity
scene do you know what Jesus is called
in
Greek you know he's called he is the
icon of the invisible God do you know
what the Greek word icon is icon in your
Greek New Testament Jesus is called the
icon the visible representation of the
invisible God he's called an icon
because the Greek word is icon where we
get icon
an image if God was against images why
did he have Jesus become flesh in order
to become the physical image of the
invisible God let me show you the word
icon Jesus is the
icon where we get the word icon here it
is let me show you the word icon you
don't even need to read
Greek you see it you see the word do you
see it
ion e i k o n in
transliteration that's the word
icon Colossians 1:15 he is the icon and
the invisible God if God was against
statues and icons why did Jesus become
flesh in order to become the
physical icon of
God there's a
link all right let me show you now the
word icon in the Lexicon one
second watch
here
to man that word's hard for me to say oh
you Greeks dude here it is here's what
it
means an image a statue
that's what the Greek word means a
statue an
image
representation here it is an image a
statue Jesus is the living
statue
icon of the invisible God